No one knows who dug the 30-foot-long tunnel near the site of this year's Pan-American Games in Toronto.
没人知道是谁在多伦多今年泛美运动会会址附近挖了这条30英尺长的隧道。
A bizarre tunnel found near one of the venues for the upcoming Pan-Am Games has sparked fears of an imminent terror attack.
在即将到来的泛美运动会场馆附近发现的一条离奇隧道，引发了人们对可能发生恐怖袭击的担忧。
Rarely has a dirt tunnel received so much attention.
很少有一条土隧道能受到如此多的关注。
No one knows why it was created. Do you think someone told their kid to dig to China and the kid actually tried?
没人知道为什么要挖它。你觉得会不会是有人告诉自己的孩子挖洞挖到中国去，而孩子真的去尝试了？
It's not just the sophistication that police say is troubling, but the lack of suspects or a motive.
警方表示，令人不安的不仅是隧道的精良程度，还有缺乏嫌疑人和作案动机。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: When something unexplained like this happens, of course, people go nuts speculating about what it could be. That's actually what our program is about today. In this case, the media pondered whether the tunnel would be used to plant a bomb at the upcoming Pan-Am Games nearby. The Pan-Am Games are like an Olympics for North and South and Central America.
当发生这样无法解释的事情时，人们当然会疯狂猜测它到底是什么。这正是我们今天节目的主题。在这个案例中，媒体猜测这条隧道是否会被用于在附近即将举行的泛美运动会上安放炸弹。泛美运动会就像是南北美洲的奥运会。
OK, what I used to do in the ravine when I was a kid is, run around, play hide and go seek. We'd play, like, apple war. We'll go fishing. But I started my first tunnel probably when I was in elementary school. I would go in the creek, walk around. And this was something on my mind. I wanted to build a clubhouse.
好吧，我小时候在沟壑里常做的事就是到处乱跑，玩捉迷藏。我们会玩所谓的“苹果大战”，还会去钓鱼。但我大概是在上小学时开始挖第一条隧道的。我会走进小溪，四处走动。这事一直在我的脑海里。我想建一个俱乐部会所。
I had five or six attempts, and I think the sixth one was the huge tunnel that the guys found.
我试过五六次，我觉得第六次的那次就是那些人发现的那个巨大的隧道。
(SUBJECT) NICK KOEHLER: I've heard him call it sort of the future of clubhouses.
我听他把那个叫做未来俱乐部会所之类的东西。
OK, I did this because it was something I always wanted to be doing, but I know I should have grown out of it. And I knew that, OK, if I build a tunnel, it came from childhood reasons, but at the same time, if I build it, who knows? I could probably hang out there, turn that childhood dream into a man cave, a bunker, whatever you call it, just a place to go hang out. And if there's something that happened, like a natural disaster or something that would happen, I could go there if there's a blackout, turn on the generator, charge my phone, even make a small meal down there just to bring back up to my house.
好吧，我这么做是因为这是我一直想做的事，但我知道我早就该过了那个年纪了。而且我知道，好吧，如果我建一个隧道，它是出于童年的原因，但同时，如果我建了它，谁知道呢？我可能可以在那里闲逛，把那个童年梦想变成一个男人窝、一个地堡，或者随便你怎么称呼它，就是一个可以去闲逛的地方。如果发生了什么事，比如自然灾害之类的，如果停电了，我可以去那里，打开发电机，给手机充电，甚至可以在下面做点简单的饭菜带回我的屋子。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Back when Elton would go to the tunnel, his sisters did not know exactly what he was doing, but they knew something was up. For months while he was digging the thing, he would come home just covered in dirt, tracking dirt everywhere. Anora though he was building some kind of underground house and grilled him about it, but he wouldn't say.
埃尔顿以前去隧道的时候，他的姐妹们并不确切知道他在做什么，但她们知道肯定有什么事。在挖那东西的几个月里，他回家时总是浑身是泥，到处都带着泥土。安诺拉以为他在建某种地下房屋，并盘问他，但他什么都不肯说。
Yes, she's recording.
是的，她在录音。
I'm recording. This is live recording coming from West Brooklyn's Community AC office.
我在录音。这是来自西布鲁克林社区咨询办公室的现场录音。
I started reporting this story in the fall of 2013.
我从2013年秋天开始报道这个故事。
This is Radio Rookie Lorraine reporting live.
这是广播新秀洛林在现场报道。
I hadn't really been going to school for over 2 and 1/2 years. So I transferred to an alternative high school for kids who dropped out but are trying to come back and graduate. We all have assigned counselors. We call them ACs.
我已经两年半没怎么去上学了。所以我转到了一所替代性高中，那是为那些辍学但试图回来并毕业的孩子准备的。我们都有指定的辅导员。我们称他们为AC。
OK, so I'm here with my own AC, Elizabeth.
好的，我现在和我的AC伊丽莎白在一起。
(HOST) RAINY: They check in with us every day.
他们每天都会找我们核对情况。
So how have I been as a student?
那我作为一个学生表现如何呢？
Lorraine, when I first started, Lorraine was only a name on my roster, because she would never come to school. And now she's here every day. She's doing what she needs to do, and she's a potential June graduate.
洛林，我刚开始的时候，洛林只是我花名册上的一个名字，因为她从来不去学校。而现在她每天都来。她在做她该做的事，并且很有可能在六月份毕业。
Definite June graduate. Clear that up. You know, got to clear that one up.
绝对六月毕业。说清楚点。你知道，得把这一点澄清一下。
Since I never came to school when I first transferred here, Elizabeth only knew me by my school ID picture.
因为我刚转学过来时从来没去过学校，所以伊丽莎白只通过我的学校证件照认识我。
So my first impression of you, I saw your picture, I saw a little girl in size with a black eye. So I thought to myself, what's going on? I said, did you get into a fight? And you said, no. But you were like, it's a long story. You'll get to know me.
我对你的第一印象，我看到了你的照片，看到一个身材娇小、眼睛被打青的女孩。所以我心里想，发生了什么事？我说，你打架了吗？你说，没有。但你说，说来话长。你会了解我的。
I had a black eye for the whole first week. I thought people were thinking that I got beat up by a girl or something, that I'm soft. Nicole's my best friend, but I call her my stepsister, because my mom and her dad used to date. We all lived together, kind of like a family. I'm the only one who calls her Nicole. Everyone else calls her by her nickname.
第一个星期我的眼睛一直是青的。我以为人们会认为我是被哪个女孩揍了之类的，认为我很软弱。妮可是我最好的朋友，但我叫她我的继姐妹，因为我妈和她爸曾经约会过。我们住在一起，就像一家人一样。我是唯一叫她妮可的人。其他人都叫她的昵称。
(SUBJECT) NICOLE: My name's Nicky Boombox, but no.
我叫尼基·轰炸机，但不是。
She was with me when I first met-- I don't want to use his actual name.
她和我在一起时，我第一次见到——我不想用他的真名。
(INTERVIEWER) RAINY: What should his name be in my story?
他的名字在我的故事里应该叫什么？
Doodoo-face.
大便脸。
I'm going to call him "Tony," the guy who became my first serious boyfriend. I met him the summer after eighth grade. By the time we started dating, I was 14, and he was 21-- six years, six months, and six days older than me-- 666. It's creepy, right? Nicole remembers when we met him.
我要叫他“托尼”，那个成了我第一个真正男朋友的家伙。我是在八年级后的那个夏天遇见他的。我们开始约会时，我14岁，他21岁——比我大六岁六个月零六天——666。很诡异，对吧？妮可记得我们遇见他的时候。
But In the beginning-- don't get me wrong-- he fooled me too. He fooled all of us. I really thought he was actually, really good. I was like, oh my god. He's really nice. I would never expect him to actually ever lay a hand on you.
但在最初——别误会——他也骗了我。他骗了我们所有人。我真的以为他其实非常好。我当时想，噢天哪，他真的很贴心。我绝不会想到他竟然真的会对你动手。
So what do you think drew me to him in the first place? What made me start liking him?
那你觉得当初是什么吸引了我？是什么让我开始喜欢他的？
His looks. Can't deny it. The fact that he's older.
他的外表。这一点不可否认。而且他比我大。
He's short, with tan skin, big, pretty eyes, and an Italian schnoz. He has tattoos and a clean-cut beard. When you think of that arrogant guy that all the girls want, that's Tony. He walks with confidence, dresses flashy, and wears big chains.
他个子不高，皮肤黝黑，有一双漂亮的大眼睛，还有一个意大利式的鼻子。他有纹身，留着修剪整齐的胡子。当你想到所有女孩都想要的那个傲慢家伙时，那就是托尼。他走起路来很有自信，穿着华丽，戴着大金链子。
But he also made you feel like you were special, like you were wanted. He was actually putting some effort into it. He would text you back. He would pick you up from the school. He didn't even try to kiss you the first time you hung out. The poems, the song, the rap he made on Facebook.
但他也会让你觉得你是特别的，你是被需要的。他确实在上面花了一些心思。他会给你回短信。他会从学校接你。我们第一次在一起时，他甚至没想吻你。那些诗、那些歌、他在Facebook上做的饶舌视频。
He made a video of it. The lyrics went something like "don't worry, baby. It doesn't matter about the age." Back then, Nicole took a video of me watching it. I really couldn't stop smiling.
他做了一个视频。歌词大意是“别担心，宝贝。年龄并不重要。”那时候，妮可拍了一段我看着视频的录像。我真的止不住微笑。
(SUBJECT) NICOLE: Oh my god.
噢天哪。
Oh, you're cheesing OD. I've never seen you cheese like that.
噢，你笑得太夸张了。我从来没见过你笑成那样。
When we first got together, he liked that I was smart, and young, and pretty. He wanted to shape me into his perfect wifey. Before I got to the age where he says girls become whores. I was getting 90s when I started the ninth grade. I would show him my report card, but he didn't pay it any mind. He just saw high school as a place for guys to bag girls. He didn't tell me to skip school. He just punished me when I went. He'd ignore me after I came back or show up at school and flirt with girls in front of me.
我们刚在一起时，他喜欢我聪明、年轻又漂亮。他想把我塑造成他完美的妻子。在我还没到他说女孩会变坏的那个年纪之前。我上九年级时成绩一直得90分。我会给他看我的成绩单，但他根本不在意。他只把高中看作是男生猎艳的地方。他没让我逃学。但他会在我上学后惩罚我。他会冷落我，或者出现在学校里当着我的面和别的女生调情。
So I just hung out with him in his room all day instead of going to class. I didn't want  him to think I was cheating. I wasn't even talking to Nicole.
所以我整天只在他的房间里跟他呆在一起，而不是去上课。我不想让他觉得我在出轨。我甚至没有和妮可说话。
Everything you thought was just about him. You just completely stopped caring about everything, and he really had that control over you.
你以为的一切都只是关于他。你完全不再关心任何事了，他确实对你有那种控制权。
How did I look back then?
那时候我看起来怎么样？
Look? You looked like a ghost. Completely dead, skinny as hell. You still looked good. Don't get me wrong, but you still had that dead look on your face, like you weren't happy at all.
样子？你看起来像个鬼。完全死气沉沉，瘦得要命。你看起来还是很好看，别误会，但你脸上的那种死气沉沉的神情还在，好像你一点也不快乐。
He was verbally abusive way before he became physically abusive. He talked to me so nasty that I could feel it. The bruises clear up, but the words stick with you, and they change how you act. He would tell me you're boring, you're awkward, you're the weirdest of the weird, you'll never fit in anywhere.
在他开始身体虐待之前，他已经在言语上虐待我了。他对我说话太恶毒了，我能感觉得到。淤青会消失，但那些话会一直跟着你，改变你的行为方式。他会告诉我你很无聊，你很尴尬，你是怪人中的怪人，你永远不会融入任何地方。
And I believed him. I didn't feel like I belonged anywhere. I didn't talk to anyone anymore, including my mom. I lied to her about how old he was and started coming home late or not at all.
我相信他了。我觉得我不属于任何地方。我不再和任何人说话，包括我妈妈。我骗她说他多大，开始回家很晚，甚至干脆不回家。
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: I was livid. I wanted you home.
我当时气疯了。我想让你回家。
This is my mom. She used to be a drug addict, but she's been clean for 10 years now. She's pretty ditzy and forgetful, but she is definitely there for me.
这是我妈。她曾经是个吸毒者，但已经戒毒10年了。她有点傻乎乎的，健忘，但她确实一直支持我。
What were you doing then?
那时候你在做什么？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: Worrying, cursing, yelling.
担心，咒骂，大叫。
At me.
对我。
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: At you. At him.
对你。对他。
Nothing she did worked, because I wouldn't let it. She knew I was the only one that could stop myself from seeing him. The first time he hit me was because I was looking through his Facebook. I caught him messaging his ex, so he slapped me across the face. He was yelling at me, telling me to get out. It escalated from there. Then, one night, two years into our relationship, we went to his friend's birthday, and he got really drunk.
她所做的一切都没用，因为我不让。她知道我是唯一能阻止自己去见他的人。他第一次打我是因为我在翻他的Facebook。我抓到他在给他的前任发信息，于是他扇了我一巴掌。他在冲我大吼大叫，让我滚出去。从那以后，事情就升级了。然后，有一天晚上，在我们交往两年后，我们去了他朋友的生日聚会，他喝醉了。
I went to sleep at his place and woke up to him pouring water on my face and dragging me out of bed by my hair. He was yelling and calling me names, like, a dirty whore, and a slut, and a piece of trash. He slapped me and grabbed things from around the room, like lighters and medicine bottles, and threw them at me.
我在他家睡着了，醒来时他正往我脸上泼水，拽着我的头发把我拖下床。他在大吼大叫，骂我，比如，脏女人，荡妇，垃圾。他扇我耳光，从房间周围抓起东西，比如打火机和药瓶，朝我扔过来。
He was screaming that he hopes my mom dies. I had choke marks on my neck. But he wasn't really choking me to cut off oxygen. It was more like choking me to grab me and throw me around. After he did that, I went over to Nicole's. My mom showed up there and started freaking out and crying when she saw me. So I walked down the block to my friend Steven's house.
他尖叫着说他希望我妈死。我的脖子上有掐痕。但他掐我并不是为了切断氧气。更像是为了抓住我并把我扔来扔去。在那之后，我去了妮可家。我妈出现在那儿，看到我时开始崩溃大哭。所以我走到街区那头去了我朋友史蒂文家。
You came, and then I seen you. And once I seen you I just felt bad. And then you started crying, and you told me you didn't see it yet. So I brought you in my bathroom, and I made you look. And you didn't want to look at it. So I told you you weren't leaving until you looked at it.
你来了，然后我看到你了。我看到你之后就觉得很难过。然后你开始哭了，你告诉我你还没看过伤口。所以我把你带进我的浴室，让你看。你不想看。所以我告诉你，不看完你就别想走。
When I looked in the mirror I saw a face covered in tears, red and swollen with blue marks on my cheeks, under my eyes, on my neck, and on my arms. I just couldn't believe I was looking at my own reflection.
当我在镜子里看到时，我看到一张布满泪水的脸，红肿着，脸颊、眼睛下、脖子上和胳膊上都有青色的印记。我简直不敢相信我在看着自己的倒影。
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: When he hit you I wanted to have him arrested, but you wouldn't let me.
当他打你时，我想报警逮捕他，但你不让。
My mom promised me she wouldn't call the police, but it was a trick, because she knew my brother would.
我妈答应我不报警，但那是骗我的，因为她知道我哥哥会报警。
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: They came. They tried to talk to you, but you wouldn't give him up.
他们来了。他们试图和你谈话，但你不愿意把他供出来。
I saw the cop car outside, so I hid in the bathroom. The cops stood outside the door and kept asking me if I got hit. He was like, just say, yeah. That's all you have to say. I said, no. So they didn't press charges.
我看到外面的警车，就躲在厕所里。警察站在门外，一直问我有没有被打。他当时说，就说，是的。这就是你需要说的全部。我说，没有。所以他们没立案。
(INTERVIEWER) RAINY: What did you guys-- you guys filed a report or something? What did you guys do?
你们是怎么——你们提交了报告还是什么的？你们做了什么？
After that happened, he and I didn't talk for a week. Then he showed up in my school. He had this really sad face on. He brought me a burger. He doesn't know how to say sorry, so I guess the whole act was kind of like an apology. We walked around the neighborhood for a couple of hours. He played one of those toy vending machine games with the arm, and he got me a baby blanket with a dog head and tail.
那件事发生后，我和他有一个星期没说话。然后他出现在我学校。他脸上带着那种非常悲伤的表情。他给我带了个汉堡。他不知道怎么道歉，所以我猜这一整套动作就像是道歉一样。我们在附近逛了几个小时。他玩了那些玩具自动售货机游戏，用爪子抓到了一个带狗头狗尾的婴儿毯。
It wasn't much, but the look on his face was just so sad that-- I don't know-- it convinced me to go back. He was overly nice at first-- extra big smiles, longer kisses-- but then he started talking about how you got to put your girl in her place. He kept accusing me of cheating on him, and I just had enough. So after two months, we finally broke up, and I moved back in with my mom.
虽然没什么大不了的，但他脸上的表情太悲伤了——我不知道——这说服了我回去。他起初表现得好得过头了——超大的笑容，更久的吻——但他开始谈论如何把你这个女人“摆在你的位置上”。他一直指责我对他不忠，我实在受够了。所以在两个月后，我们最终分手了，我搬回了妈妈家。
How do you feel since I came back?
你觉得自从我回来后感觉如何？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: Oh, so relieved that I have my baby back.
哦，太欣慰了，我的宝贝又回来了。
This is Nicole again.
这是妮可。
I still hate him.
我还是恨他。
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: I'll always hate him.
我永远会恨他。
She's confessing murder.
她在承认谋杀。
Actually, just because this is recorded, I'm kidding. Anyway--
其实，因为这是在录音，我在开玩笑。总之——
So I'm looking through my old diary. I mean, I had diary entries from the very, very beginning. A star means we got into an argument. A heart means it was a good day. The circle means he ignored me the whole day.
我在翻看我的旧日记。我的意思是，从最开始我就有日记记录。星号表示我们吵架了。爱心表示那是美好的一天。圆圈表示他整天无视我。
Good things about breaking up with Tony? I get to hang out with Nicole and I get to go back to school. Bad things about breaking up with Tony? I'm alone.
和托尼分手的好处？我可以和妮可一起出去玩，我可以回到学校。分手后的坏处？我很孤独。
I feel like I just need someone to shock me, to take my mind off things. And I don't have anyone now, even on Christmas. My mom was at her boyfriend's house, so I was on my own. I was just in my bed, looking at Facebook. Tony posted a status, saying how Christmas will never be the same. He obviously meant that for me, since it was our anniversary.
我觉得我只是需要有人来刺激我，让我分心。现在我一个人都没有，即使是在圣诞节。我妈在她男朋友家，所以我得自己过。我只是躺在床上刷Facebook。托尼发布了一条动态，说圣诞节永远不会一样了。他显然是说给我听的，因为那是我们的纪念日。
My heart stopped for a second. When he's in my life-- I don't know-- it's like it's the one thing that just gets me going, like, really gets me going. I just want him to understand that he was wrong about everything he accused me of, so I decided to write it all on a letter. I included a playlist with an even number of FU songs and I miss you songs, and a weird little purple rock I got from the Museum of Natural History.
我的心跳停了一秒。当他在我生活中时——我不知道——那就像是唯一让我动力十足的事情，就像是真正让我兴奋的事。我只是想让他明白，他指责我的一切都是错的，所以我决定把这些写在一封信里。我还附上了一个播放列表，里面有偶数首咒骂歌和我想你歌，还有一件我在自然历史博物馆买的奇怪的小紫色石头。
We started talking, but only over Facebook. I wanted to keep my distance. For a couple of weeks, we went back and forth. He wasn't being pushy. He was actually being really sweet, so I agreed to see him. And I ended up staying the night.
我们开始说话了，但仅限于Facebook。我想保持距离。几周来，我们断断续续地交流。他没有咄咄逼人。他其实表现得非常贴心，所以我同意去见他。结果我留宿了。
(HOST) COURTNEY STEIN: This is Courtney, Rainy's Radio Rookies producer. Rainy was working on her story with me for about a month before she disappeared. She stopped returning my texts at Christmas time. When school started again in January, Rainy wasn't there. Then, a few weeks into the semester, her English teacher, Erin, emailed me. Rainy was back. I met her after school and set her up to record a diary.
这是考特尼，雷尼的广播新秀制片人。雷尼在失踪前和我一起做她的故事大概一个月了。她在圣诞节期间停止回复我的短信。一月学校开学时，雷尼不在。然后，学期过了几周，她的英语老师艾琳给我发了邮件。雷尼回来了。我放学后见到了她，让她开始录制日记。
I'm just going to put it on hold. You don't have to do anything. You can even just put it in your pocket.
我只是把它暂停一下。你什么都不用做。你甚至可以把它放在兜里。
OK, I just press play when I want to record? Or is it recording already?
好的，我想录音时只要按播放键就行了？还是它已经在录音了？
It's already recording. You don't even have to worry about it.
它已经在录音了。你不用担心。
I will be back. All classrooms have teachers. Leave, leave, leave. You know, I don't think I'm supposed to be in this room. Oh, but I'm going to be in here anyway. So I've obviously got back with my ex. I've been on the lookout for abusive behavior, to see if he's going to revert back to his old ways.
我会回来的。所有教室都有老师。离开，离开，离开。你知道，我不觉得我应该待在这个房间里。哦，但我还是要待在这里。所以很明显我又和我前男友复合了。我一直在防范虐待行为，看看他是否会回到以前的老路上。
I mean, at first, he was, you know, how you'd expect-- sweet, gentle, nice, caring, all those things. But I've noticed some behavior that I don't like. About a week, two or three weeks ago, he told me to shut up in a nasty way. I mean, it's not that big of a deal, but I felt like it was a sign that the pattern might re-emerge. I mean, he is rough just by nature. I don't think that's abusive, though. I think that's just how he is. But at times, I don't really like it.
我的意思是，起初，他是，你知道的，正如你所期待的那样——贴心、温柔、友善、关心，所有这些。但我注意到了一些我不喜欢的行为。大约两三周前，他以一种恶毒的方式让我闭嘴。我的意思是，这没什么大不了的，但我觉得这是一个模式可能会复发的信号。我的意思是，他天生就很粗鲁。虽然我不觉得那是虐待。我觉得那只是他的本性。但有时，我确实不喜欢那样。
I know that in a lot of ways he's a really bad person. But I know that he could be a good person. No one's all bad. We slip back into our old routine of me never going home or going to school almost immediately. He became slowly more disrespectful and then violent, again. I was surprised, because I really hoped it was going to be different this time.
我知道他在很多方面确实是个烂人。但我知道他也可以是个好人。没有人全是坏的。我们很快又回到了我从不回家或去学校的旧习惯中。他慢慢变得更加无礼，然后又变得暴力了。我很惊讶，因为我真的希望这次会不一样。
I remember being 13, and just being like, I just want to be 17. When I'm 17, that's going to be the perfect age. And I get to 17, and it's like, wow. This is what 17 looks like? This is what my 17 looks like?
我记得我13岁的时候，心里想，我只想17岁。当我17岁时，那将是完美的年龄。我到了17岁，就想，哇。这就是17岁的样子？这就是我17岁的样子？
(HOST) COURTNEY STEIN: Rainy barely showed up to school for the rest of the year. She was supposed to graduate but didn't. From the beginning, Rainy told me she wanted to tell this story so she could try to understand herself and figure out why she was ever with him. She said that if she understood, that might help her leave. So over the course of the next year, Rainy would reemerge for a day or two, go to school, record a bit, and then be gone again.
雷尼在那年剩下的时间里几乎没来过学校。她本该毕业的，但没毕业。从一开始，雷尼就告诉我她想讲这个故事，这样她就能试着了解自己，弄清楚为什么她会和他在一起。她说如果她明白了，那可能会帮她离开。所以在接下来的一年里，雷尼会重现一两天，去学校，录一点，然后又消失了。
OK, so my first question is, what are the signs of teen dating abuse?
好的，那么我的第一个问题是，青少年约会虐待的迹象是什么？
(SUBJECT) SARAH GONZALES: So what's extremely common in teen relationships is the forced absence from school. Right? So if I'm forcing you to be absent from school, I'm affecting your grades, which will then affect how you graduate, if you graduate, when you graduate.
在青少年关系中极为常见的是强迫逃学。对吧？所以如果我强迫你逃学，我就影响了你的成绩，这进而会影响你如何毕业，你是否毕业，你何时毕业。
That's actually exactly what happened to me. It's funny you brought that up. I should be a senior now, and I'm still not graduating. So I am usually looked at as someone who could be considered a strong female. I don't let guys mess with me. I don't put up with stuff like that. But then somehow I'm in this relationship that I allow myself to get stepped over.
这其实正是发生在我身上的事。你提起这个很有意思。我现在应该是高四了，但我还是没毕业。所以我通常被看作是一个可能被视为坚强的女性。我不让男生摆布我。我不容忍那样的事情。但不知何故，我陷入了这段我允许自己被践踏的关系。
(SUBJECT) SARAH GONZALES: The only thing that I would change in that is the "allowed" part. People, even with good intentions, unintentionally blame victims or survivors. So we say things like, if that person just had self-esteem, it would be OK. What that tells someone is that it's your fault because you don't have the esteem to leave, when that's not really the case.
我唯一想改变的一点是“允许”那个词。人们，即使是出于好意，也会无意中责怪受害者或幸存者。所以我们说的话像是，如果那个人有自尊心，那就会没事。那告诉别人的是，这是你的错，因为你没有尊严离开，而事实并非如此。
I mean, I do, and I don't understand the answer. Because it doesn't make sense why being happy 5% of the time makes you stay. I don't know.
我的意思是，我有尊严，但我理解不了答案。因为即便只有5%的时间快乐却让你留下，这说不通。我不知道。
(SUBJECT) SARAH GONZALES: You know, you do love your partner, right? And so a lot of times, what you really want is just for the abuse to stop, but you still want to be with your partner.
你知道，你确实爱你的伴侣，对吧？所以很多时候，你真正想要的只是虐待停止，但你仍然想和你的伴侣在一起。
I mean, we have happy times. We'll cuddle and laugh. Sometimes he even cooks or makes us tea.
我的意思是，我们有快乐的时光。我们会依偎在一起大笑。有时他甚至会做饭或给我们泡茶。
(SUBJECT) SARAH GONZALES: Well, you can say, OK, I should be leaving. And if you don't, it's just like, today wasn't the day that I was leaving. As opposed to blaming yourself, because then that might keep you there a little longer. It's like, OK, it didn't happen today, but it can happen tomorrow.
嗯，你可以说，好吧，我该离开了。如果你没有，那就像是，今天不是我离开的日子。而不是责怪自己，因为那可能会让你在那里待得更久。就像是，好的，今天没发生，但明天可能会发生。
Lorraine, what are you doing with your life? I know you're at that boy's house--
洛林，你的生活怎么过？我知道你在那个男孩家里——
My assigned counselor has been leaving me voicemails. I never even listened to them.
我的指定辅导员一直给我留语音邮件。我甚至从未听过它们。
(SUBJECT) ELIZABETH: So don't shut down because you're with this boy. We already spoke about this. The weather was bad. You don't do snow-- I know all your excuses in the book. But right now, the weather's better, so you should have been here today. So, obviously, if I don't see later, that means it's not good. OK? So call me or show up. Bye.
所以不要因为和那个男孩在一起就自暴自弃。我们已经谈过这个了。天气很糟。你不去上雪天——我知道你所有的借口。但现在，天气好转了，所以你今天本来应该来这里的。所以，显然，如果我没看见你，那就意味着情况不好。好吗？给我打电话或者过来。再见。
When the new cycle started, I told him I had to go back to school. And not even five minutes later, he held me down and started sucking on my neck. I was like, get off, babe. You're hurting me. He didn't do it for very long, but he did it hard enough to leave a huge, dark, purple mark. I guess he was trying to mark his territory.
新周期开始时，我告诉他我得回学校。结果还没过五分钟，他就把我按住，开始吸我的脖子。我说，走开，宝贝。你弄疼我了。他没做太久，但他弄得很重，留下了巨大的深紫色印记。我猜他是在试图标记他的领地。
(SUBJECT) MAN: What are you doing here?
你在这里做什么？
When you haven't gone to school in a really long time, and you come in with a hickey, that looks bad. I tried to cover it up. I felt like my teachers are going to look at me so disappointed.
当你很久没去学校，然后带着一个吻痕进来时，看起来很糟糕。我试图遮住它。我觉得我的老师们看着我会非常失望。
Testing, Courtney, Courtney, hello. School just ended about 15 minutes ago, and today is the first day I've been in school for at least the past month. Not something I'm very proud of.
测试，考特尼，考特尼，你好。学校刚才放学约15分钟了，今天是我至少一个月来第一次来学校。这不值得我骄傲。
I'm sure you're thinking, who the hell stays with someone like him for this long? Believe me, I get it. I think I'm an idiot. I don't know what makes me stay.
我相信你在想，谁会跟这样一个家伙在一起这么久？相信我，我懂。我觉得自己是个白痴。我不知道是什么让我留下。
I mean, one time I was trying to leave, and he took my sweater into the bathroom and peed on it. He spit in my face in front of company more than once. There are some things he's done to me that are just so embarrassing I've never told anyone. I don't want people to look at me and say, you allowed him to do that to you, and you're still with him? So I just shut down and don't talk to anybody, including Nicole. This is what she thinks of the situation.
有一次我想离开，他把我的毛衣拿到浴室里并在上面撒尿。他在客人在场的情况下不止一次往我脸上吐口水。他对我做过的一些事情太尴尬了，我从没告诉过任何人。我不想让人们看着我说，你允许他那样对待你，而且你还跟他在一起？所以我只是封闭自己，不和任何人说话，包括妮可。这就是她对这种情况的看法。
(SUBJECT) NICOLE: I feel like, basically, you don't leave, because when you come home, there's really no one here.
我觉得，基本上，你没离开，是因为当你回家时，这儿真的没有人。
She means that my mom works a lot and spends weekends at her boyfriend's. So she's not always home.
她的意思是，我妈妈工作很忙，周末都在她男朋友那里度过。所以她并不总是待在家里。
Personally, you really have nobody. I feel like that's the real reason, because you're used to that environment, always being with him every day. I know it's hard. You always say it's hard for you to make new friend. Meanwhile, it's really not that hard.
个人而言，你真的没有人。我觉得那是真正的原因，因为你习惯了那个环境，总是每天和他在一起。我知道这很难。你总是说你很难结交新朋友。其实，这真的没那么难。
I mean, I didn't have that much of a hard time making friends when I was younger. I wasn't like that. I don't know when it changed, or how it changed.
我的意思是，我年轻时交朋友并没有那么困难。我以前不是那样的。我不知道这是什么时候改变的，或者它是怎么改变的。
(SUBJECT) NICOLE: Because he shut down your whole confidence. It's hard to come back when you don't talk to anyone like you haven't talked to or interacted with a person in how long? And you expect to interact--
因为他磨灭了你所有的自信。当你不再和任何人交谈，就像你多长时间没和人交谈或互动过了？而你期望去互动——
Because you're talking like you're twisted. Why are you laughing? Are you laughing at me because I'm an idiot?
因为你说话的样子像是你扭曲了。你笑什么？你笑我是因为我是个白痴吗？
I'll think about all the stuff he'd done to me and just be like, I hate him, I hate him, I hate him.
我会想到他对我做过的所有事情，然后就像，我恨他，我恨他，我恨他。
(INTERVIEWER) RAINY: What are you talking about? You're not putting me on nothing. I'm going to stab you in the face. No, chill. Oh. All right, bye.
你在说什么？你没给我什么。我要捅你的脸。不，冷静点。哦。好吧，再见。
He doesn't.
他不会的。
You don't scare him.
你吓不倒他。
I think this wouldn't have happened with someone my own age. I mean, Tony was the first guy I was ever seriously with. I didn't know anything, really, about being in a relationship. So I trusted him on how he thought things should be. In the beginning, I was always worried that he would break up with me. I remember the first time he did. I was just shivering, literally shaking. I didn't know how to be without him.
我觉得如果对方和我同龄，就不会发生这种事。我的意思是，托尼是我真正交往的第一个男生。我真的对处于一段关系中一无所知。所以我相信他关于事情应该如何的看法。刚开始，我总是担心他会跟我分手。我记得他第一次那样做的时候。我简直在颤抖，真的是在发抖。我不知道没有他该怎么活。
I can't believe that I've been with him for five years now. That's over a quarter of my life. The first 50% of my life, I was probably pissing my pants and my mom was on drugs. So I blocked a lot of it out. Then I was fat for the next five years. Then I have this [BLEEP]. I'm wasting my life.
我不敢相信我已经和他在一起五年了。那是我四分之一的人生。我生命的前50%，我可能还在尿裤子，而我妈妈在吸毒。所以我阻断了大部分记忆。接下来的五年我都很胖。然后我遇到了这个[消音]。我正在浪费我的生命。
(INTERVIEWER) RAINY: Oy vey. Yup, so another diary.
哎呀。好的，又是日记。
The longer I live with him, the more angry I get. He won't let me express my emotions. He won't let me cry. He won't let me yell. Some girl kept coming around. She would not leave him alone. I wanted to beat her up, but then she started telling me what was actually going on, that she'd been seeing him on and off for the past two years. This isn't the first time he's cheated on me, but she's the youngest. She just turned 15. And Tony's 25 now. He's doing the same thing to her that he did with me.
我和他住得越久，我就越生气。他不让我表达情绪。他不让我哭。他不让我叫。有个女孩一直缠着他。她怎么都不肯放过他。我想揍她一顿，但她开始告诉我到底发生了什么，说过去两年她一直和他断断续续地往来。这不是他第一次出轨，但她是最小的。她刚满15岁。托尼现在25岁了。他正在对她做和我一样的事。
I always felt like I needed this huge epiphany or something crazy big to happen to end the cycle. But something just broke inside me. A switch turned off. And that was it. I'm done with him.
我一直觉得我需要某种巨大的顿悟或什么疯狂的大事来结束这个周期。但我的内心有什么东西断了。开关关上了。就是这样。我和他完了。
(INTERVIEWER) RAINY: All right, mom, I want you to be as truthful as possible. And don't think I'm going to get mad at you for anything you say.
好了，妈妈，我希望你尽可能诚实。不要以为你会因为你说的任何话而让我生气。
I haven't really been home since I got together with Tony. I haven't had a chance for my mom to baby me. I feel like I missed out on that, for a lot of my life, actually.
我和托尼在一起后我就没怎么回过家了。我没机会让我妈像疼小孩那样疼我。我觉得我错过了很多，其实在我生命中的大部分时间里。
What did you say when I said me and him  were breaking up this time?
当我这次说我和他分手时，你说了什么？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: I said, thank God.
我说，谢天谢地。
Did you believe me?
你相信我吗？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: I prayed so. Yeah, I wanted to believe you. Yes, absolutely.
我祈祷是真的。是的，我想相信你。是的，绝对。
Are you watering your truth down maybe just a little bit because I got mad at you last time you said that?
你是不是把你的真心话稍微冲淡了一点，因为上次你说那话时我冲你发火了？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: Yeah, you did get mad at me the last time I said that.
是的，你上次我说那话时确实对我发火了。
The last time you said-- what the hell did you say? Oh, I said that we were broken up, and you said, for how long this time? Two weeks, you're going to be back together. Something like that. Is that how you really felt?
上次你说——你说什么鬼话来着？哦，我说我们分手了，你说，这次又能坚持多久？两周，你们又要复合了。类似那样。那是你的真实感受吗？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: Well, that's how it's been, basically. I mean, the longest you've broken up so far is six months.
嗯，基本上一直就是那样。我的意思是，到目前为止你们分手最长也就六个月。
Do you think my relationship with him is like a drug, like an addiction?
你觉得我和他的关系像毒品，像瘾吗？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: Absolutely. Yes, I do. I think it's a drug that you can't seem to stop. You want it. You know it's no good for you. And you want it. You want to caress it. You want to hold it. You want it to be in your body, to be next to your body. You want to suck in every minute, thinking it's life. And then, when it's over, you feel that it's not.
绝对。是的，我这么认为。我觉得那是一种你似乎无法戒掉的毒品。你想要它。你知道它对你没好处。但你还是想要它。你想爱抚它。你想抱着它。你想要它在你的身体里，想贴着你的身体。你想吸入每一分钟，以为那就是生命。然后，当它结束时，你觉得它不是。
Does my behavior remind you, in any way, of your own?
我的行为有没有让你想起你自己的行为？
Absolutely, just like me, only mine was with the drugs, and I couldn't stay away.
绝对有，就像我一样，只是我的是毒品，我也无法远离。
Do you think I was in any way more susceptible to being in an abusive relationship because of how life was growing up?
你觉得因为成长过程中的生活，我是否更容易陷入一段虐待关系中？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: I actually didn't see that coming, but I do see you as a caretaker. You want to take care of a man, and I'm kind of the same way.
我其实没想到会那样，但我确实把你视为一个照顾者。你想照顾一个男人，我也差不多是这样。
If this-- if this could record my face. Yeah, so I don't know if there's anything else I'm supposed to ask you.
如果这个——如果这个能录下我的脸。好吧，所以我不知道还有什么我该问你的。
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: I'm glad you're not with him now.
我很高兴你现在不和他在一起了。
So before I end this recording, do you believe this is the last time?
所以在我结束录音之前，你相信这是最后一次吗？
(SUBJECT) RAINY'S MOTHER: From your lips to God's ears, yes, I'm going to believe. Definitely   power in prayer
从你的嘴巴到上帝的耳朵，是的，我会相信。祷告的力量确实是伟大的。
I can't even hold eye contact with him. It's just so hard. It's just awkward. It's just so awkward. It's like when you're on the subway, and you think you saw someone that you know. You take a quick glance. You meet eyes, and you look away as quick as-- you look away, because it's awkward.
我甚至无法和他有眼神交流。这太难了。这只是尴尬。它太尴尬了。就像你在地铁上，以为看到了认识的人。你快速瞥了一眼。你们对视了，然后你立刻看向别处——你看向别处，因为它很尴尬。
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: Larry's dad worked so late, sometimes Larry would go days without seeing him. And even when they did have a rare chunk of time together, it wasn't exactly quality father-son time. It was actually the opposite.
拉里的爸爸工作很晚，有时拉里好几天都见不到他。即使他们偶尔有难得的共处时间，那也不是什么高质量的父子时光。实际上恰恰相反。
Especially if we're having dinner together or something, and my mom's not home, he'll call me down. And I'll set the table, and we'll just both be picking at the food and not saying a word.
特别是在我们一起吃饭的时候，如果我妈不在家，他会叫我下来。我会摆好餐桌，我们俩都只会挑挑拣拣吃点东西，一句话也不说。
(INTERVIEWER) BIANCA GIAEVER: And then it would be complete silence the entire time you guys are eating?
然后你们吃饭的时候全程都是彻底的沉默？
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对。
(INTERVIEWER) BIANCA GIAEVER: Can you list off the things that he would say to you that you could understand?
你能列出他会对你说的那些你能听懂的话吗？
It really just came down to whether I was one, healthy, or, two, hungry. And if I was not hungry, and if I was healthy, then I was good. It was definitely upsetting, especially growing up. But I think it got to a point where I just didn't really register that feeling anymore. I just started feeling nothing for him when I would see him. He would just be basically a wall to me, just like a third wall, and I'd walk right past him.
这确实归结为我是否健康，或者我是否饿了。如果我不饿，并且我健康，那我就没问题。这绝对令人沮丧，尤其是在成长的过程中。但我认为到了某个阶段，我就不再真正感受到那种感觉了。我看到他时对他没有任何感觉。他对我来说基本上就是一堵墙，就像第三堵墙，我会直接从他身边走过。
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: When Larry was eight, his little brother was born, and his parents sent his brother to Chinese school. And as he grew up, his brother could talk to his dad. The two of them got along great. Larry would watch the two of them making jokes with each other, laughing, smiling. Before that, he said he didn't even know his dad could laugh.
拉里八岁时，他的弟弟出生了，他父母把弟弟送去了中文学校。随着成长，他弟弟能和爸爸交流。他们俩相处得很好。拉里会看着他们互相开玩笑，大笑，微笑。在此之前，他说他甚至不知道他爸爸会笑。
I just really felt angriest towards him. I just felt strong resentment. Because, in my head, I thought that he definitely does not love me. And so I'm not going to care about who this person is.
我真的对他感到最愤怒。我感到强烈的怨恨。因为在我的脑海里，我想他肯定不爱我。所以我不在乎这个人是谁。
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: When Larry was 14, the construction business that Larry's family owned in China took off. It was making more money than the takeout restaurant, so Larry's dad moved back to China in order to send more money home. He wrote Larry a letter to say goodbye.
拉里14岁时，他家在中国拥有的建筑生意蒸蒸日上。它比外卖店赚的钱多，所以拉里的爸爸搬回中国以寄更多的钱回家。他写了一封信给拉里告别。
So it's about six pages long. On the left side, it's the Chinese. And on the right side, it's the English that my aunt translated.
所以它大概有六页长。左边是中文。右边是我姑姑翻译的英文。
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: Larry got the letter after his dad had already gone. Here are some excerpts read by Larry.
拉里在他爸爸走后收到了这封信。以下是拉里朗读的部分摘录。
"Son, I remember the days after you were born. I was thankful because your arrival brought me a brilliant outlook in life. When I wrote this letter, I struggled tremendously. However, it is a father's duty to mentor his son. I cannot communicate with you. Time flies. In the blink of an eye, I will turn 40 years old. In another two or three years, you will leave mom and I to attend college, learn the necessary skills, be independent.
“儿子，我记得你出生后的那些日子。我很感激，因为你的到来给我带来了灿烂的人生前景。写这封信时，我挣扎得很厉害。然而，教导儿子是父亲的职责。我无法和你交流。时光飞逝。眨眼间，我就要40岁了。再过两三年，你就会离开我和你妈去上大学，学习必要的技能，独立。
Sorting and organizing your books to keeping your desk clean will leave a good and lasting impression on others. Before you go to school every morning, remember to eat something. Do not pressure yourself. As long as you are unafraid of working hard, there will be a path for you. I cannot speak English, and I've been able to support my family all these years, so relax and do your best.
整理好你的书籍，保持书桌整洁，会给别人留下美好而持久的印象。每天早上上学前，记得吃点东西。不要给自己太大压力。只要不怕吃苦，路就在你脚下。我不会说英语，但我这些年来一直能养活我的家人，所以放松点，尽你所能。
Thank God for giving me the courage to write this letter to my oldest son. I believe deeply that to gain anything, you must surrender something. Conversely, Anything that you surrender you must gain something back. Pardon for my sharing. Pa."
感谢上帝给我勇气写这封信给我最大的儿子。我深信，要获得任何东西，你必须放弃某些东西。相反，任何你放弃的东西，你一定能获得某种回报。请原谅我的倾诉。爸爸。”
I read it through the first time, and by the end of it, I'm really crying. It just really hit me hard, because that was the first time he ever said, I love you. Every line just made me start crying over again.
我第一次读完它，读到最后，我真的哭了。它真的深深打动了我，因为那是我第一次听到他说“我爱你”。每一行都让我忍不住再次哭泣。
(INTERVIEWER) BIANCA GIAEVER: This is like one moment where you realize everything you thought was totally wrong?
这就像是一个瞬间，让你意识到你所想的一切完全是错的？
Yeah, I felt so guilty, because it was basically my fault for not understanding that this is actually how he feels.
是的，我感到非常愧疚，因为这基本上是我的错，因为我不理解这就是他的真实感受。
(INTERVIEWER) BIANCA GIAEVER: Was some part of you, like, why didn't you tell me this earlier?
你有没有一部分在想，为什么你以前不告诉我这些？
No, because my dad's main focus was making sure we have a place to live and we have food. In my head, I envision my dad working, like, 14 hours a day, standing by hot oil, cooking, lugging around boxes and stuff like that. So when I put it into perspective, I realized, you know, he bears a lot more burden than I will ever bear.
没有，因为我爸爸的主要精力是确保我们有住的地方，有饭吃。在我的脑海里，我设想我爸爸每天工作14个小时，站在热油边上做饭，搬运箱子之类的。所以当我换位思考时，我意识到，你知道，他承受的重担远比我将来要承受的多得多。
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: What Larry saw in the letter was, his dad had been thinking about him all this time. He had been noticing him and worrying about him. So Larry gets this amazing letter that totally changes how he sees his father, and he never writes him back. Remember, he was 14, in middle school. He wasn't mature enough to know how to respond, but he decided he'd study Chinese someday, so he could finally talk to his dad. He started taking classes in college, but he's still not fluent.
拉里从信中看到的是，他爸爸一直都在想他。他一直在关注他，为他担心。所以拉里收到了这封神奇的信，彻底改变了他对他父亲的看法，但他从没回信。记住，他当时14岁，在初中。他不够成熟，不知道该如何回应，但他决定以后要学中文，这样他终于能和他爸爸说话了。他在大学开始上课，但他还不够流利。
OK, Larry, you want to just--
好的，拉里，你想直接——
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: We got Larry's dad on the phone and played the recording for him. For the first time, his dad heard his son speak in a language he could understand. Here's what his dad heard.
我们接通了拉里爸爸的电话，并为他播放了录音。这是他爸爸第一次听到他的儿子用一种他能理解的语言说话。这是他爸爸听到的内容。
Dear Ba, when I think about our house when I was a kid, I think about mom cooking greens in soy sauce chicken. I think about the whole family yelling at each other over the dinner table, typical Fujianese. It's so loud. And then I think about you reading a book on the couch, totally silent. Sometimes, Mom would come up to me and say, go spend some time with Dad. I remember saying, there's no point. We can't even speak to each other. She'd say, just try it. But I just shrugged and went back to my room. Then I got your letter.
亲爱的爸爸，当我想到我小时候的家时，我会想到妈妈用酱油炖鸡做的蔬菜。我会想到全家人在餐桌上大声争吵，典型的福建人风格。吵死人了。然后我想到你在沙发上看书，完全沉默。有时，妈妈会过来对我说，去陪陪爸爸。我记得我说，没意义。我们甚至无法交流。她说，试试看。但我只是耸耸肩回了房间。然后我收到了你的信。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
I've read it countless times since high school. I treasure it and read it sometimes when I feel down about myself. It makes me feel better about myself, about family. But the most important thing about the letter was that, for the first time, I felt like you were speaking directly to me. And I was so surprised by how emotional you were. And when I read that letter, I thought, here's someone I care about, I appreciate, and I want to get to know better.
自从高中起，我读过无数遍。我珍藏着它，有时在我对自己感到沮丧时也会读它。它让我对自己、对家庭感觉更好。但这封信最重要的一点是，这是第一次，我觉得你在直接对我说话。而且我非常惊讶你竟然如此情绪化。读那封信时，我想，这里有一个我关心、感激并想进一步了解的人。
I had so many questions for you at first-- what your childhood was like? What would you do for fun? Who were your friends? Did you know you were going to be working in a Chinese takeout restaurant for two decades? Did you enjoy it? Did it mean anything to you? But then I realized that everything I thought about you my whole life was completely wrong, and I felt guilty that I never tried to get to know you. I'm so sorry.
起初我有很多问题想问你——你的童年是什么样的？你会做些什么娱乐活动？你的朋友是谁？你知道你会要在一家中餐外卖店工作二十年吗？你喜欢吗？它对你有什么意义吗？但我意识到我一生中关于你的所有想法完全是错的，我感到很愧疚，因为我从没试过了解你。真的很抱歉。
But it's not too late. Now that I know a little more about who you are, I want you to know who I am, where I live, where I like to go, who my friends are, what I like to do, what instruments I play. I'm learning Chinese now in school. Hopefully, one day we can actually talk about all these things for real, face to face. Till then, I'm happy to simply know how much we care about each other. I love you, Pa.
但现在还不晚。既然我稍微多了解了一点你是谁，我也想让你知道我是谁，我住在哪，我喜欢去哪，我的朋友是谁，我喜欢做什么，我演奏什么乐器。我现在在学校学中文。希望有一天我们可以真正面对面讨论所有这些事情。在那之前，我很高兴能知道我们彼此有多关心对方。我爱你，爸爸。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
(SUBJECT) INTERPRETER: Thank you.
谢谢。
So what's your reaction?
那么你的反应是什么？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
I'm quite touched.
我很感动。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
(SUBJECT) INTERPRETER: I haven't quite caught up to my own emotions at this moment. I felt this is the most-- the most you've ever talked to me.
我此刻还没平复自己的情绪。我觉得这是你跟我谈过最多的一次。
Yeah, so is there anything that you've wanted to ask me about my life?
好的，那有什么你想问我关于我生活的事情吗？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
In terms of planning for your life, I care about whether you have a girlfriend or not. You start to get worried when you're getting to your 20s. I know you might have your own plans, but I worry about those things. You're on.
关于你的人生规划，我关心你有没有女朋友。当你进入20岁时，你会开始担心。我知道你可能有自己的打算，但我担心那些事情。该你了。
I don't have a girlfriend right now. But besides that, I just wanted to know was there anything in the letter that surprised you?
我现在没有女朋友。但除此之外，我只是想知道信里有什么让你感到惊讶吗？
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Once I listened to your letter, I felt a sense of contentment. I feel I will, from this moment on, always look at you differently. You're no longer a child, no longer a boy. And I just feel very relieved that you can express these things with me through the letter.
听了你的信之后，我感到了一种满足。我觉得从这一刻起，我会永远以不同的眼光看待你。你不再是那个小孩，不再是那个男孩。而且我觉得非常欣慰，你能通过这封信和我表达这些。
(SUBJECT) LARRY: When did you realize that you couldn't talk to me, where you realized that you couldn't communicate with your son?
你什么时候意识到你无法跟我交流，意识到你无法和你儿子沟通的？
There were moments when your mom wasn't around, and all I could figure out with you is whether you're hungry or not. And if you are, I would give you food, but anything beyond that was impossible. And those are very painful moments. And I also hope that you don't have to make choices like this between your family and your work. I hope you have a happy family, that you will have a different life than what I did.
有几次你妈不在身边时，我唯一能和你弄明白的就是你饿不饿。如果你饿，我会给你食物，但除此之外的一切都做不到。那些时刻非常痛苦。我也希望你不用在家庭和工作之间做出这样的选择。我希望你有一个幸福的家庭，你会拥有和我不同的人生。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Yeah. I mean, I understand everything that you did. And for what you did, I don't think you're any less of a father.
是的。我的意思是，我理解你所做的一切。至于你的付出，我不觉得你作为一个父亲有任何不足。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Well, thank you, my little boy, for saying this.
好的，谢谢我的小男孩这么说。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
But I do feel regretful and guilty as a father, as a husband, for not being able to take care of the family.
但我确实作为一个父亲、作为一个丈夫感到后悔和愧疚，因为没能照顾好这个家庭。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
No, it's OK now. I love you, and we're here. I just waited a really long time to say that.
不，现在没事了。我爱你，我们在这里。我只是等了很久才说出那句话。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
Well, you're just like me. I'm not very good at expressing. I like to hold my feelings, my thoughts to myself, and maybe that's something we can work on together. We would tell each other more. We would tell each other sooner how we feel, what we think.
好吧，你就像我一样。我不擅长表达。我喜欢把感受和想法藏在心里，也许这是我们可以共同努力的地方。我们会告诉对方更多。我们会更早地告诉对方我们的感受和想法。
Yeah. Yeah, I definitely, definitely look forward to building our relationship and just learning more.
是的。是的，我绝对非常期待建立我们的关系并多了解彼此。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[说中文]
I am thousands of miles away from my son, but I feel like I'm sitting next to him for the first time.
我离我儿子几千里远，但我感觉第一次坐在他身边。
(HOST) BIANCA GIAEVER: At this point, everyone in the room is crying-- Larry, me, my producer, even the translator. Larry and his dad text regularly now. Larry's Chinese is now good enough where he can understand most of what his dad says, and he can put the rest into a translation app. I read their texts, and it's not deep. It's just normal.
此时此刻，房间里的每个人都在哭——拉里、我、我的制片人，甚至翻译。拉里和他的爸爸现在经常发短信。拉里的中文水平现在好到可以理解他爸爸说的大部分内容，剩下的他可以放到翻译软件里。我读了他们的短信，并不深奥。它们只是普通的日常。